good morning John it's Thursday March
8th I'm walking downtown to try and find
some people to give peeps - there are
technically a lot of people around but
they're all in cars having a hard time
getting them to notice me free peeps
free free Pete free no I'm not stopping
it's kind of snowing and cold
I kind of hate you a lot starting to be
a lot more people around this is the
kind of town I live in my general
opinion is that it's going to be quite
difficult to get rid of these peeps
there are a lot less people downtown
than I thought they would be I usually
only go downtown at night so it kind of
assumed that it would just be a bunch of
college students who are kind of mostly
drunk but it's not drunk college
students it's business people and soccer
moms on herons they don't look like they
want peeps also I don't know how I'm
going to film them because people
usually aren't okay with that kind of
thing I think I'm gonna have to hide the
camera this looks like a pretty good
place to hide a camera
you
one three feet
don't and you might want to take the pay
phone there's a great
you like things
got a bunch
now there
okay this looks promising there's a
bunch of punk rockers down the street
but it's going to be hard to record them
so I'm just going to turn the camera on
and leave it in my pocket you hear what
happens yeah yeah ridiculous number of
people I would love some peeps I mean I
have like a hundred of them Oh Dan will
commendably eat amongst yourself
definitely I've been trying to give him
the way all day people are like go chew
and give me peace well nice you don't
have to take off but I would appreciate
it if you did we're going to a little
bit like I do
I'm Hank by the way come the day I'm
Kurt Kurt hey nice to meet you machine
gun that's uh twelve peeps and your
handbag yep twelve peeps what's going on
I do not want you to choke yourself no
you got this for a living
freak show watch just watch focus
seriously people die eating peeps all
the time
could be timing you
yeah
but not like one more man put it in
there like I'm amazing how much your dog
doesn't care about peeps how you feeling
that's a lot of peeps I feel like I have
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man like
fighting the Ghostbusters in my stomach
okay see you guys definitely thank you
very much
those guys are probably the most worthy
recipients of peeps I have ever seen so
I went back and timed him and it took
him one and a half minutes to do what it
took me six minutes to do however I
actually felt really really nauseous at
the end of it and I hope Kurt is okay
because that was a lot of peeps really
fast anyway I have to keep this under 4
minutes so I'll see you tomorrow